Speaker 1: We have a voicemail.
No, you can call the voicemail number really
whenever you want.
And many people call it times of day that
are times I tend to be sleeping.
But that's OK because you can call any time
of day.
Here is a caller.
It is the AGYEMAN.
The Egemen has really been on an A.M. lately,
and I guess he's blaming me for his daughter
wearing a mask.
Listen to this.
Speaker 5: Hi, David.
So I'm headed out on Saturday afternoon with
my 15 year old daughter and she says, oh,
darn it, Dad, I forgot my mask.
But I tell her, kid, you don't need one.
You're double vaccinated kid to go.
And she says, well, you know, I know I don't
need one, but I just want people to look at
me like I'm like on my kid now has the attitude
that as you because you and so many people
keep perpetuating the wear masks, even if
you're vaccinated idea we got to stop this.
You know, that is virtue signaling.
Speaker 1: I, I admit that it's virtue signaling.
I know.
Why is that man blaming me.
Speaker 5: Know it.
Let's move past this.
I want to see somebody without a mask and
not know if they're on antibiotics or vaccinated.
I don't want to judge them by that anymore.
You don't need to wear them anymore.
That's what the CDC says.
So I don't know.
Let's not worry about hurting other people's
feelings.
So, brother, my kids listening to this now
I'm going to get judge.
Speaker 1: Yeah, we'll listen to the man should
be judged.
And I don't know what is going on from the
standpoint of parenting over there.
But listen, I've said I don't it's almost
like Groundhog's Day here where I keep saying
the same thing.
We've been following the CDC guidelines all
along.
And so why would we now all of a sudden stop
following CDC guidelines?
What I have admitted is merely for issues
of I'm making a social decision where if I
stick my head into a grocery store, as I did
yesterday, and everybody's still wearing a
mask, I just put the mask on partially because
I get recognized at the grocery store all
the time.
And I don't think it would be a great thing
for me professionally if I am photographed
or seen as being the only unvaccinated people
in the grocery store.
So it's total virtue signaling.
I agree with that.
But I think what the man's daughter has learned
and this this is actually a great lesson,
is that we can understand the science, we
can understand the CDC guidelines.
We can feel safe not wearing a mask if we
are vaccinated, but.
For social reasons, we might say, here's something
I'm going to do just to make it easier on
me, some people don't care if everybody's
staring at them because they're the one person
not wearing the mask and that's one personality
type.
But the egg man's daughter seems to have a
sense of self where she says, you know, I'd
rather feel safe either way, but just throw
the mask on even though I don't need it just
so I don't attract attention to myself that
I may not want.
That's a perfectly reasonable calculation
to make in society.
As I said before, I never thought I needed
a mask to just be out by myself on my bike,
on the bike path.
But at the point at which everybody was doing
it, I just did it.
And it just made things easier for me.
And there is value in that as well.
All right, Egemen, a little egg, everybody.
I hope you're doing well.
Shalom.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Jeffrey Toobin, after being caught exposing
himself during a zoo meeting, is back and
he's apparently been promoted on CNN.
It's wild what's going on.
North Carolina has decided to end that really
stupid CocaCola ban.
You probably forgot about it.
But remember when there was a boycott of Coke
in North Carolina?
Because they what did they.
I don't even remember what the controversy
was.
They.
Crap, what what did coach do, they supported
voting rights, I guess it was, or I don't
even remember.
We'll talk about it.
And Apple iPhones will soon be able to hold
your ID.
Privacy experts are on edge.
We will talk about those stories and more
on today's Bonas show.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
Join Pakman dot com.